il y a il y en a un qui a lâché une
bombe aujourd'hui c'est celui que je
considère comme mon ami je l'aime
énormément c'est Laurent Ruquier Laurent
est revenu sur les coulisses de son
départ de France 2 après plus de 20 ans
et il dit avoir été traité comme un
malpropre lui qui a pourtant fait les
belles heures du service public on
accède il a fait 7 ans je crois d'accès
avec On a tout essayé après il a fait un
autre accès et puis bien sûr en deuxième
partie de soirée ça a été un véritable
carton petit récap et on reparle de ce
qu'il a dit regardez ce qu'il a dit
Laurent
pendant des années Laurent Ruquier a été
l'un des visages phares de France
Télévisions mais cet été il a créé la
surprise en annonçant avoir claqué la
porte du groupe pour atterrir
prochainement sur BFM TV la raison de sa
colère avoir été prévenu seulement juin
qu'il n'aurait plus de prime j'ai été
averti au dernier moment comme un
malpropre et comme si je ne comptais pas
sur cette chaîne dans cet entretien
accordé à Télé-Loisirs l'homme qui a
passé 23 ans sur France Télévisions ne
cache pas sa rancœur on a le droit de ne
pas employer les gens mais on peut être
élégant avec eux et avoir du respect
pour le passé
ce qu'on a des infos là dessus moi j'en
ai quelques-unes je vous dis la vérité
donc je voulais donner dans un instant
mais c'est vrai que voilà moi en télé
c'est vrai que je peux pas blairer grand
monde
mais c'est vrai que Laurent Ruquier pour
le coup ça fait partie des gens je vous
dis c'est un des seuls mecs vrai dans le
métier voilà c'est un mec qui dit qui
pense voilà il t'appelle il y a un
problème il t'appelle il dit les choses
c'est pas un mec qui va te faire des des
des entourloupes et c'est pour ça que
j'aime beaucoup ce gars là et je vais
vous dire je l'aime pour autre chose
c'est qu'à un moment moi j'ai aimé la
classe du gars quand un moment vous
faites une émission tout seul vous êtes
en deuxième partie de soirée sur France
2 vous marchez très bien parce que ça
marchait très bien pour lui et que la
direction vient vous voir il vous dit je
vais vous mettre je vais te mettre
quelqu'un avec toi donc la salami et qui
dit ok bah pourquoi pas et je sais ce
qui s'est passé Laurent a fait le
rendez-vous à français parce qu'on me
l'a raconté et il a dit à son producteur
bah écoute il va me mettre les assalam
avec moi je lui dis ouais pourquoi pas
bah pourquoi pas non mais
en fait Laurent c'est un mec voilà il
sait un kiffeur il voit pas le max c'est
pas un mec qui va faire des vies ce qui
va faire des trucs je voilà j'ai
vraiment je on se côtoie depuis des
années on a été en face en radio on
était en face en télé voilà on s'est vu
plein de fois et c'est vrai que c'est
quelqu'un moi j'aime bien ce qu'il a pas
de vie et c'est vrai que là je vous dis
la vérité moi on me dit demain on va te
mettre Léa Salamé avec moi
oui elle va être là-bas oui non mais
c'est vrai c'est vrai pas Léa Salamé
voilà euh pas venir à côté de moi donc
Laurent Ruquier c'est tu dis pas Laurent
Ruquier On va te mettre quelqu'un à côté
de toi je suis désolé ou tu fais une
autre émission si tu as envie de faire
un truc avec Claire Salamé et tu fais
une autre émission et tu gardes ok mais
c'est vrai que ça a été aussi un projet
finalement un peu plus lointain c'est
l'histoire euh d'avoir l'idée de faire
ce changement de façon voilà un peu plus
progressif après bon moi ce que je veux
dire c'est un langage que moi parce que
je suis pas le porte-parole que vous le
connaissez pas hyper bien et puis je
connais pas super bien le gosse mais moi
personnellement ce qui m'a ce qui m'a
marqué durant ces dernières années c'est
vraiment de communication d'une chaîne
avec celui qui pour moi est un des
piliers enfin les dernières années sur à
la télé si on met cinq noms il y a
Laurent Ruquier dedans sur la découverte
d'artistes sur des émissions phares
enfin il a fait les plus belles heures
de France 2 ça serait respecte un
minimum et je vais te dire moi moi je
mets souvent les animateurs dans la tête
je mets souvent Ligue 2 Ligue 1 Ligue
des Champions Laurent Ruquier c'est
Ligue des Champions mais il a pas été
traité en joueur de Ligue des Champions
malheureusement puisque là sur la fin de
saison précédente moi j'ai pu constater
que il n'y avait aucun appel aucun même
un petit café avec ton ton patron pour
qu'il dit juste tu as bien bossé cette
saison ça fait des bonnes audiences aux
enfants de la télé rien du tout quand il
faisait des bonnes audiences aux enfants
de la télé ils n'avaient jamais un petit
SMS parce que peu importe le niveau où
tu es tu as toujours envie qu'on te dise
bravo
je m'appelle pour les audiences voilà
c'est ça qui va vous faire bah lui aussi
il va s'appeler du coup
bravo bah ouais ça je te rappelle 2
minutes je suis sur le pin donc mais du
coup du coup il parle parce que je veux
terminer il part il a il est en bon
terme avec Delphine mais c'est juste que
en dessous des finances il y a un
monsieur qui s'appelle Simon Gomez moi
je l'adore moi Simon Gomez ou c'est un
bon pote à moi mais alors et simplement
mon point de vue encore une fois parce
que je ne parle pas pour l'orange
vraiment c'est j'insiste là-dessus je
suis désolé mais on va on va faire un
petit un petit débrief de fin de saison
avec avec son animateur phare on lui dit
quel projet on a on est transparent avec
parce que c'est le respect qu'il mérite
et en l'occurrence il ne l'a pas eu
c'est d'en faire et à sa place je serai
parti bah moi j'estime que quand tu
t'appelles Laurent Ruquier et ben tu
mérites un peu plus de considération moi
je trouve ça normal surtout avec tout ce
qu'il a fait pour la chaîne je suis sûr
que le moteur tu es pas d'accord
dans toutes les boîtes parfois tu te
fais virer comme un comme un sac on
t'envoie un recommandé on dit
rendez-vous pour un licenciement et tu
prends ça en pleine gueule après 25 ans
de boîte ça c'est fait après comme c'est
Laurent Ruquier qu'on l'a dit les
grandes heures lui il classe avec la
Salamé il a doublé moi je suis sûr que
c'est ça c'est on va pas la mettre toute
seule au feu parce qu'elle va se planter
Laurent Ruquier va t'expliquer un peu
toutes les mécaniques du soir tu vas
voir tu vas comprendre ça va être très
bien et après tu prendras sa place je
suis d'accord avec Hugo juste un moment
donné tu convoques Laurent Ruquier tu
dis voilà tout ce que tu as fait avec On
a tout essayé tout ce que tu as fait en
deuxième partie de soirée tu es pas
n'importe quoi tu es pas un chiffon on
va te convoquer et on a déjà eu la même
histoire avec Patrick Sébastien qui
s'est qui s'est plaint pareil donc
France 2 à un moment donné France Télé
vous avez des animateurs on vous dit pas
qu'il faut les voilà dites-leur au
revoir sérieusement avec classe ça
existe aussi dans des boîtes on peut
dire au revoir un salarié avec classe
interdit là je me tourne vers toi parce
que là tu es tu peux pas avoir un
meilleur témoignage que le tien ah comme
on dit en Corse Aqua mbok ferme ta
bouche tu es venu ici pour fermer ta
bouche
d'une manière de
boucle on a eu cette discussion à tout à
l'heure
avec
et c'est pas à vous chérie que je veux
dire ça c'est un monde extrêmement
violent c'est le miroir c'est des
connards moi j'ai déjà été viré du jour
au lendemain comme une malle propre
c'est considération après tu fais pas ce
métier si tu sais pas où tu mets les
pieds donc appelle-le dis-lui allô
Laurent ce qui me rassure c'est que un
type comme Laurent Ruquier qui est
effectivement une grande star un grand
nom de la télévision qui a fait des
choses reste encore sensible à ce genre
de monde moi je connais des gens je
citerai pas de nom qui en ont rien à
faire et pourquoi tu parles de moi
s'il avait voulu faire les enfants de la
télé toute la saison avec le nombre de
téléspectateurs ça marche bien c'est de
manière même plus en faisant restant sur
France Télévision en changeant mais
c'est un homme d'honneur
donc là il va kiffer ailleurs bah merci
bon espère qu'il va kiffer en tout cas
Laurent je fais des bisous on va passer
au top de l'actu avec cette image qui
fait énormément parler elle montre un
agent de la RATP en train de frapper
violemment un passager qu'il avait
arrêté c'est une image qui a été filmée
mardi soir et qui est devenue virale en
quelques heures regardez
[Musique]
alors l'agence c'est un monde de la GPSR
un groupe de protection et de sécurité
des réseaux qui a pour mission de
veiller à la sécurité des personnes et
des biens et de protéger les agents de
l'entreprise de son et son patrimoine
Gilbert LED oui alors ce que là j'en dis
c'est que avant cette scène que l'on
voit le jeune homme en question frappe
un de ses collègues tape dans une valise
de quelqu'un se rebelle et le menace de
mort voilà ça c'est la première chose il
faut expliquer aussi que la RATP a très
vite réagi enquête interne et dans le
communiqué de la RATP ils expliquent que
le caractère est manifestement
inapproprié par rapport à la réaction de
l'agent ce qui veut dire que la RATP va
le lâcher Cyril il risque d'être
sanctionné parce que quoi qu'il arrive
cet agent ne peut pas réagir comme ça
voilà si c'était cette image qu'on
voulait vous montrera passer tout de
suite au top un des infos du jour hier
on en a parlé avec Michel Marie de la
triste histoire de Patrice Charlemagne
ce professeur de 51 ans tué dans la nuit
de dimanche à lundi sa femme a été
passée en garde à vue afin de vérifier
sa version des faits et elle a
finalement terminé par avouer le meurtre
de son mari regardez
l'image d'un couple uni c'était il y a
un an et demi aujourd'hui à Dunkerque
les aveux de la compagne de Patrice
Charlemagne trouble la population
s'y attendait pas conseillère municipal
de Dunkerque écrivaine professeur ici
personne ne comprend elle avait d'abord
affirmé aux enquêteurs que des
cambrioleurs avaient assassiné son
conjoint les secours la retrouvent dans
ce champ lundi dernier en état de choc
son bébé dans les bras le corps de
Patrice Charlemagne lui se trouve dans
la maison du couple au premier étage tué
de trois coups de couteau le couple
avait un enfant de 20 mois le mobile du
meurtre reste inconnu alors très vite il
y a eu des incohérences dans le
témoignage de de Justine sont l'heure à
laquelle elle appelle il y avait un
décalage par rapport à ce que les
policiers ont noté sur la téléphonie
précise tout de suite ils ont eu des
témoignages selon lequel le couple
battait de l'aile et en examinant les
téléphones ils ont vu des échanges très
virulents entre les deux donc se sont
dit est-ce que la thèse du cambriolage
n'est pas complètement bidon et puis il
y avait sur les mains de la jeune femme
une entaille qui correspond à une
entaille sur le gant qui a été retrouvé
avec les couteaux et l'ordinateur juste
à côté de la maison donc ils se sont dit
il y a trop de coïncidence et elle a
fini par avouer en garde à vue garde à
vue qui est prolongée maintenant reste à
savoir si c'est un crime passionnel
c'est à la agit seul ou si c'était
prémédité avec des complices voilà en
tout cas on a eu la voix
avec Michel Marie exactement avec Michel
c'est cette thèse qui est largement
privilégiée même si elle est encore
présumée innocente vous le savez cette
semaine reçoit un invité particulier en
France il s'agit du roi Charles III et
l'histoire du jour c'est donc l'arrivée
de Charles III en France il est arrivé
hier à Orly et sur un programme
particulièrement chargé mais nous on a
des images que personne n'a que Bertrand
Deckers était sur place il était en
duplex avec nous hier afin de commenter
en direct cette grande soirée organisée
pour le déplacement du souverain
britannique alors on a tout entendu qui
était là-bas qui a mangé qui n'a pas
mangé il va tout nous dire il est avec
nous sur le plateau pour faire un bilan
tu passage du roi sachez que lui le
passage du roi pour lui c'est voilà
c'est c'est comme quand moi voilà je je
vais au Cap d'Ail
[Musique]
par le couple présidentiel évidemment
Emmanuel Macron et son épouse Brigitte
c'est un dîner évidemment extrêmement
important et surtout qui clôt cette
première journée de visite l'Élysée dit
même qu'il existe une amitié entre les
deux hommes et que Charles III donnerait
beaucoup d'importance à ce que dit
Emmanuel Macron notamment sur les crises
internationales
[Applaudissements]
ça va mon frérot c'est un petit cadeau
pour merci merci
[Rires]
bravo est-ce que le roi Charles Emmanuel
Macron se kiffe ou est-ce que c'est
Tommy non non si si il y a une vraie
amitié de ouf oui 6 il s'apprécie
vraiment d'ailleurs on a vu ah c'est
reproché par la presse d'ailleurs
Emmanuel Macron ne cesse de toucher le
roi à trois reprises quatre reprises et
à aucun moment le roi il a le droit de
toucher le roi non normalement non parce
que le roi est couronné c'est une figure
sacrée pour les anglicans il est chef de
Dieu sur terre
oui il est l'incarnation il est
l'incarnation de Dieu puisqu'il est chef
de l'Église anglicane c'est à ce titre
là que normalement on ne peut pas le
toucher mais croyez-moi qu'il aurait
fait ça avec Elisabet 2 dans la seconde
il aurait compris sans qu'il n'aurait
rien faire
il se serait directement
et donc ici vraiment parce que moi je
sens que c'est Tommy moi je sens que
Charles il est pas comment vous fait des
fois
on rappelle quand même que le Président
c'est qui le plus fort entre Charles et
Emmanuel le plus fort d'un point de vue
en bras de fer non mais en taulier genre
c'est qui le plus taulier des deux c'est
qui voilà que j'aurais mon restaurant
c'est qui qui paye
[Rires]
c'est le plus riche
non mais genre quand c'est qui qui a le
dessus sur l'autre mais si c'est Cédric
si ça arrive à maintenant forcément que
c'est le président est-ce que il y a
plus de respect voilà
j'ai envie de savoir
un coup de pression à l'autre Charles ce
diplomatique tout ça
dis-moi pourquoi Emmanuel Macron il a
choisi Versailles
Emmanuel Macron il a choisi Versailles
parce que Versailles c'est une vitrine
et Emmanuel Macron il voulait vraiment
que ça en jette et je alors c'est très
critiqué Versailles à Cyril mais ce que
l'on peut peut-être apporter dans ce
débat où on dit ça peut on te Versailles
coûté du tout le palais il est mis à la
disposition des grandes réceptions de la
République je reçois toi attention alors
et donc
il a fait un discours Charles oui hein
français ça mais il a fait un discours
un tout petit peu dire ça a marché Cyril
le fait de sortir Versailles vous savez
quoi parce que hier comme j'étais sur
place je vois pas enquêter j'en peux
poser des questions 250 journalistes ont
demandé pour être accrédité uniquement
pour Versailles et parmi ces 250
journalistes à grosse majorité était
internationaux et beaucoup de
journalistes du Moyen-Orient et pourquoi
du Moyen-Orient parce que c'est
Versailles qu'il est facile c'est ni
Emmanuel Macron ni Charles III c'est Les
Orres qui les calaient être déployés
sous la galerie des Glaces on sait quand
même que la population du Moyen-Orient
quand elle voyage elle a les moyens
c'est elle qui va dans les gros groupes
élevés nage Dior Chanel donc je pense
qu'il va vraiment y avoir des retombées
économiques aussi en matière d'image tu
auras
alors les invités semblaient tous très
très contents de cette soirée c'est une
soirée
après on va parler de la bouteille de
vin parce que ça va être le débat du
jour à 2500 boules là bouteille de vin
je peux te dire à 2000 2800 572 276 2800
boules la bouteille de vin frère Titan
voler une espèce
[Applaudissements]
regardez la bouteille de vin elles sont
non mais regardez les réactions des
sorties du dîner on était quelque chose
le roi le président était sensationnel
et le dîner était très grande ambiance
un grand bonheur et
délicieux les vins sensationnels il y a
une histoire entre la France et
l'Angleterre qui est très forte la
France et l'Angleterre ont une fois de
plus retrouver leur profonde amitié et
c'était un très bon moment et puis de
deux très beaux discours des deux des
deux chefs d'État donc c'était c'est
chouette
alors vous allez voir parce que là on a
vu la soirée de Charles on va parler de
Charles il a même plus Adidas
il aurait pu venir nous voir aussi
c'était pareil
tu sais pourquoi pourquoi
il mesure 15 cm non tellement il était
loin c'est vrai tu as vu le Charlotte
lui parler mais tu ne bouge pas alors
justement on va parler de la folle
soirée de mercredi